I get the honor of introducing our next
couple but before I introduce them I'd
like to give you a little orientation to
why we have developed a program and they
will then tell you about the program
this is a presentation that doesn't
start out with a first slide of
introductions when I was nine I would
have liked these huge temper tantrums
and it became really hard for me to do
anything feeling like there's something
wrong with me and that I'm innately
flawed was part of what I think made it
so hard I mean I I was nine I was
contemplating suicide she was so sad and
so hollow and I don't know that you
would even be able to fathom that seeing
her now there was nothing there there
was
she just basically given up so this is
often what the way families come in to
our family connections program filled
with pain with a lot of difficulty in
being able to manage what's going on in
their lives we also know though that
family members staying the course with
their relative is very important and we
have a study somehow of the slides got a
little confused here so I won't worry
about them we did a study about 12 years
ago on a construct called expressed
emotion and what that study showed was
contrary to any other psychiatric
diagnosis that the more emotionally
involved family members stay the course
with their relative the better the
patient or the relative fairs over a one
year time span that was what the
research showed so given what families
go through in the fact that things are
very difficult they're worrying about
suicide they're worrying about
self-injury and on the other hand their
emotional involvement is crucial for
their relative we realized that we
needed to come up with some sort of
program to help family members stay the
course with their relative so what
you'll be hearing today is about our
family connections program this is a
program that we now have in 16 countries
we have had maybe three four or five
thousand people who have gone through
the program over its 12-year existence
we have a waitlist that's so long I'm
embarrassed to tell you how many people
are probably on it but it is a course
that works and has changed the lives of
family members and we believe in the
long run also changes the lives of the
person with BPD research showed that
actually the levels of burden grief and
depression go down when family members
attend the course and equally important
their sense of empowerment goes up
meaning that from the skills that
they've learned they're able to manage
situations in a much more effective way
it's now my pleasure to turn over this
part of the program to Anne and Matt
Costello these are married couple with
three children they will tell you
their story but their exemplary and
being family connections leaders I don't
even know how many times they've run
this course probably maybe a dozen 15
times it's a 12-week course when they
finish the course the next Sunday they
start over again and each week there in
White Plains running the course for
family members they also run support
groups they are incredible and they
really show what families can do in
families make it can make a difference
we also have other family members out
here today who are also family
connections leaders so we want to share
with you the program hope that maybe if
you're a family member or you work with
families you can think to have them
attend the program we also do it by
telephone so it's all over this country
and as well as other countries as I said
so it's my pleasure to introduce Madden
and Costello so good afternoon welcome
to our presentation thrilled to see so
many of you still here because i know i
need a nap i'll be will be using notes
because believe it or not this is the
first time we've spoken at Yale so
that's why we will be referring to notes
first of all let me tell you a little
bit about who we are and what we do and
we'll go back and forth and then we'll
do it and when it's done it'll be over
they'll be done nice things out that
they do come to an end point we're
parents of children who deal with all
not all many of the things that we've
been talking about today on a daily
basis on a daily basis we interact with
them dealing with those things we've
been talking about every day we're a
ance a teacher she works k 26 in her
school k 25 maybe I'm a writer we're on
the nea nea BPD board and we do our best
there to serve as much as possible and
what we're going to do is going to try
to mirror what's what it's like to go
inside a family connections course so
there'll be some redundancies so you may
say well we heard that already but we're
just trying to mirror what the
experience is for parental units not
always parental units but often parental
units who come into the family
connections class we've been doing the
course for four years as Perry mentioned
we do three a year
we do at new york-presbyterian white
plains a lot of luminaries this
portraits of auto Kern Berg and other
people on the wall they look down at us
they seem ok then I they don't seem
terribly displays with us so far not
judgmental of who you expect them not to
be once it once a month we do a support
group of alumni and lately been getting
40 45 people coming to that for a little
skills review we have guest speakers
coming to do that Eric background
obviously not clinicians not researches
we've been to three trainings run by
Perry and Allen and any a BPD we've also
gone to a behavioral check training that
was done in Greenwich a year or so ago
with Adam Miller no Adam pain and Alec
Miller we went to the Naas SPD
conference in Boston brain and behavior
conferences in New York we try to get as
much information as possible because we
specifically are not trained and then we
try not to go beyond our role which is
not to be therapist but stick to the
skills that are relevant to working with
parents and as we do that's key word is
we're not therapist and as time goes by
parents begin to believe that we're
service and we have to always go back to
the skills we do a free 12 week class
two hours every Sunday morning we ask
for a very small donation that goes to
any a BPD it's manualized in other words
it's a big fat manual that we use from
its gets fatter and fatter as I collect
more information that Perry and Allen
says Eddie Perry Hoffman an alum
frazzetti put together it's a curriculum
it's an actual curriculum and we get
through the six modules in 12 weeks
we're a little behind this year because
we had some interesting weather all year
so it took us we had to cancel some
because we had some interesting Sundays
we
give current information I'm always on
the NEA BPD website I send them
everything they listen in on the talks
that are on Sunday night that are
wonderful we give them the symptoms and
I was going to go through the criteria
but that was done earlier so you know
the criteria but our family members
don't always know them so we go through
them and we elaborate on them such as
what would be the cutting and pulling of
hair and all kinds of things that they
do we have two children who have
borderline by the way our oldest child
just had a baby himself so he's in good
shape we go to all the NEA BPD functions
that we have we go to lots of
conferences with the family member we
continue to give them skills the skills
come later we start with information but
we give them skills later sharing we do
sharing we get to that of how we do the
first day sharing and we always do an
activity so that they can meet each
other and they can meet other families
and they get to talk about things that
we give them a something to talk about
like that's a good new title for a song
the will like for instance we would say
is there something you can't validate
right now or is there something you
haven't validated that you'd like to
validate and then we give them a couple
of minutes and they share and then they
come back to the group let's see we get
our families come no that's coming later
let's see we teach the families the
language that the clients get that their
children their loved ones get if they're
taking DBT so our classic one in our
house is when our son wants something
they'll say can I do a dear man on you
and so we know what he's talking about
and we'll do a dear man on him too and
we do it with love and joy and we laugh
about it we keep it light
the fam this vent the family connections
is actually complementary to whatever
dbt family members get on their own the
difference is that after our loved ones
go to therapy they come home and we have
them seven days a week and only one hour
they're in therapy so the family
connections teaches the families how to
make calm how to have the skills that
they need in order to keep things calm
and to be complementary to whatever kind
of therapy they're getting okay how do
they find the program they go through
this wonderful manager we have that has
been a virtual manager for me for a long
time Kim eluate who's sitting right
there she's our manager they go to any
AVP deep calm and there's a space there
for families and they click on families
and it's a drop-down menu and it says
families register so Kim gets all the
registrations and it always has their
address their state their zip codes
their phone numbers and things of that
sort so when I want to start a new group
I will get in touch with Kim and Kim
sends me down state New York a little
bit of Connecticut and a little bit of
New Jersey and we get the Bronx and
queens and manhattan and brooklyn and
all of that we get a lot of them the
registration goes all around the world
through canada and different countries
it's it's pretty amazing and she's
wonderful okay well we often get people
from word of mouth we get family members
who graduate from our group and then
they go and tell other family members
and so they call me you usually they'll
call me and I'll say register on the
website and type in that you've spoken
to an cost element mat nan and Kim gets
that and she sees that they've already
spoken me but they've always they've
already registered we put flyers out
usually about three or four weeks before
we start and we put them in therapy
centers we put them at the train station
we put them in the hospital we put them
at the A&P where else so you put them
anywhere there's a bulletin board
bulletin board will put them up we put
an article in the newspaper our local
newspaper guy he's always asking you
know can can you give us an update so
that's where they come so who are the
people that walk in to this room with
all these portraits in there they come
from all walks of life we get between
2025 people which is which is a lot I
think I think Perry tends to think 12 to
14 s optimum but we kind of believe how
do you say notice someone who is in
desperate straits and we were talking to
people from Clear View and silver Hill
about the need to get a parent into a
group right away and often you say you
know say I'm in crisis right now well
wait two months Oh starting from two
months in its ok you know so so we do
take people when they're there one thing
they share in common is that they've all
suffered stigma many of them most of
them have thought they've been the only
person on the block suffering for this
they felt ashamed they felt guilty
everyone else is going to Harvard that
this kids going to be an astronaut this
one's going to discover a cure for
something and I have this so they think
they're alone so they walk into this
room and there are all these other
people I thought sound like Jerry
Seinfeld there they're all these other
people in the room who shared the same
and all of a sudden for that first
moment a bit as if nothing else happened
a bit of that stigma disappears because
they're not alone and even more so into
the support group we know we've had 250
people over the past couple years and 40
or 50 show up at one of those the other
thing is they're couples usually couples
sometimes it's a single parent sometimes
one parent comes and the other is
reluctant we've actually had one parent
come in the next course the other parent
shows up and that's fine sometimes its
siblings once in a while to spouse and
occasionally it's been where they're
headed ulti 60s 70s that they've been
dealing with us all of their life though
most often you were looking at 18 to 30
year-old offspring the one thing they
also tell them the beginning is we say
to them that you and your loved ones all
heroes why and
you know they just walked in the room
feeling stigmatized so why are you
heroes because you and your loved one
are both dealing with something that
most people in the planet don't have to
deal with it and you're here and you
know whether it's climbing Everest or
diving down to the bottom of the ocean
that certainly is heroic so we kind of
reinforce that as we go along okay so
the first day they come in they're very
shy everything's very quiet prior to
their arrival I send them an email and I
send them the the attachment for module
1 so they get the module one on their
computer and they print it out i asked
them to print it out i also asked them
to write a little paragraph did i do
that with you guys a little paragraph
right Nancy did it yeah we did
paragraphs we don't always do it they
come prepared in other words to talk
about their family because sometimes
it's very hard to keep them brief
especially when you have 24 people there
do the math we have two hours and if
they're doing three minutes the day is
over so we we do have management skills
we're able to manage it and I asked them
to give me the the first name of their
loved one their age and what their
current living situation is because
somebody before mentioned i think it was
Louis about if they're at home or if
there's somewhere else ok because it's
sometimes it can be easier and you can
reconnect and reattach if they're not
living in your house we also ask them to
mention to us what is the most upsetting
symptom for yourself and what is the
most upsetting symptom for your loved
one and they bring that on the court and
they each get a chance to talk and we go
around and we share and then if we tell
them that we're probably going to have
to cut you off if you go too long please
don't be insulted we all have everybody
else to do it so I asked them when I say
can you give me a stress number at this
point they'll give me a stress number
and the stress numbers are one to ten
one you have nothing on your plate
everything's fine 10 you are way overdue
it's way over
and we get some people come in and say
well I'm 25 you know so that's us just
and then we go on to the next person if
I'm moving this too fast let me know i'm
just tryna no it's not moving no this
this this this way this way left right
okay nevermind right okay so uh the next
slide would say early days so in the
early days people people arrived and
they unlike everybody here probably now
they maybe I've heard the words
borderline personality disorder may be
heard the letters DBT than that they
really know nothing so educating them to
that it's an emotional dysregulation
disorder is key we talked about and
again we don't step out of our comfort
zone in terms of what we know but we say
it's a bite the biosocial theory of the
disorder which is there it's a genetic
component and there's a and there's a
social component namely the environment
the invalidating environment we also
discuss how it's transactional in other
words it's not this person here who's
acting this way it's a dynamic that goes
back and forth and we're possibly bring
in things that we've learned in other
conferences that sort of show that this
is not someone who's just getting angry
and breaking windows because they like
to get angry and break windows there's
something going on here and gradually
get them to the point where they accept
the fact that it is indeed disorder so
understanding the symptoms that's
exactly what matthew is saying that
they're not somebody who's just breaking
things though it appears that way and
anger is not always in the borderline
personality disorder criteria we have we
do have some families that they don't
have anger though a good many of them do
and we try to get them to understand in
many many different ways we do lots of
different brain scans we show them the
brain scans that we get that it's a it's
a chemical reaction and they don't want
to be doing this as much as you don't
want them to be doing it and we teach
them how to understand these symptoms
and then we talked about before the
skills
comorbidity right so cool and we talked
about the comorbidity and co-occurring
disorders like what will occur with
borderline personality disorder whether
it's certain aspects of anorexia whether
it's narcissism major depressive
disorder because the because they're
gonna walk in and no single person is
going to have the same exact person but
we say how many of your kids have
trouble sleeping hands go up how many
how many of your kids have been kicked
out of school hands go up how many have
had volatile relationships so they start
to see this little web of connections
even though each one and that's why
there why I thought when Louis is
talking they're really interesting
because they're unique and there's
hypersensitive in some ways that's an
amazingly good thing and also other
disorders people have other diagnosis
whether it's bipolar where they have
certain borderline features and we
talked about that we talked about the
primary diagnosis would be for example
major depressive disorder certain
borderline features so and we have the
percentages which have been come through
research that we pass on to them right
why the information before the skills
well because it's in the book that way
for starters but Alvin always says you
can you can pick and choose and you can
kind of move it around but we're very
comfortable with this because we've done
it so many times that we go through all
of the information first and we tell
them that its information heavy and then
when the skills come we all get very
excited we actually we've the skills in
all the time we always talk about
validation we always talking to talk
about judgment but if you understand the
symptoms and if you understand what's
going on you can have empathy and you
can change and empathy and change can
come slowly the as Perry said it does
reduce grief guilt burden if you've
completed the class and that's why we do
the skills later and it gets them coming
back to so one thing we do and we
actually learn this from the people who
we did our class with which is reap all
de valdivia and Louise sticks
I had a card for us one side of the cars
the rights relatives a lot of the people
walking in the room they too have lost
all rights they basically they don't
know what they have so to give them some
sense of this is your life too there are
two people living this life but the
other car other side I want to message
us briefly which is the basic
assumptions because they walk you out of
that first session with these basic
assumptions which are to look at things
to take the most benign assumption
possible so if you look at behavior
someone's in your face cursing full
stream their normal reaction is what's a
normal reaction going to be and we say
what's the benign assumption reaction
the benign assumption reaction is going
to be this person is extremely
dysregulated now they're extremely upset
and ignore not ignore all the f-bombs
but look at and that assumption is
possible and that's nothing to emphasize
and the second assumption is there's no
one or at one absolute truth we all get
a bit and it's like that Japanese we
Rashomon where there's many different
you seeing different slices of things
happening everyone's you're all having a
different experience here now some
people have interested some people did
you know them so your believing whatever
there's different experiences going on
everyone has different slice of what's
going on shameless no it's okay oh you
can't hold the mic here stand here this
will be interesting hey how about my
lovely assistant so imagine this is this
is the crisis this is the car wrapped
around the tree and the vodka bottles in
the yard the ambulance right there
please set the door get the pitcher okay
and that's what you're seeing right but
that's only part of it because if you
keep your eye on only one thing you're
going to miss everything a lot of every
other
I'm doing two shows two shows a night at
the so so we try to say that even in the
moment of the car wrecked on the tree
the vodka bottles and the police and
everything there's a lot to take in
there's a lot to see there and the
policeman will have it there their truth
your loved one will and the last one is
well the last two is everyone is doing
the best they can in the moment make
that assumption because it will keep you
regulated if it doesn't look very pretty
if you go on with the assumption that's
the best they can do at this moment just
think how that keeps you regulated and
then the corollary of that I said that
work correctly is everyone needs to try
harder or keep trying so right now
that's the best we can do and let's go
forward and explore how we can do better
we have a lot of parents would come in
and say well we're done we've had enough
this is it and they said well you're
here and that's good and they stay they
go through it and okay the court
teaching skills right um so yeah I think
I'm doing primary motions so again I
won't belabor this but many people come
in they're angry at their loved one
they're angry at themselves there's a
lot of there's a lot of anger first
session in that room and what we try to
show them is anger feeds off judgment
and it feeds off other emotions for
example let's say you loved one isn't
responding to your call where are you
it's three a.m. 2 a.m. you're worried
yeah fear you're scared those are all
primary emotions and their adaptive
because you can actually use them late
or two to work out but what happens for
most people when the person finally
comes in that door 3am boom anger so and
people struggle with this so we spend
times brainstorming all the primary
emotions what are they ah and say you
really need you know you can't it's like
it's like I'm being a race car you can't
speed past them got to slow it down come
back to what was at that core if a
stranger walking at door
I am you wouldn't wouldn't care fact
this is a loved one someone you care
about validation is the next one that we
do and a lot of them have never heard
about validation they don't know
anything about validation but it has to
be done non-judgmentally validation is
you can validate feelings you can
validate emotions a lot of them think
that the family member perceives that as
agreeing with them that they're going to
stay out all night and you say well I
see you you'd like to stay out till
three o'clock yeah okay bye and they go
and it's not it doesn't mean that you
agree with them you're simply using
validation statements we write down we
have a list of maybe 50 or 60 validation
statements that I've gotten from Alan
and I've gotten from Perry and I've
gotten from Marie Paul and I've gotten
them from all of our family members and
I send that to them they all have that
and we've actually had family members
cells they put the validation right in
their pocket and when it's one another
one is taped right where the phone is so
when the phone calls come they can
validate because it's not intuitive this
program is not intuitive it's it's not
how we were raised and if we continue to
raise our children the way I was raised
which was not so good that you can't you
can't help your borderline so the
parents have to change the family
members they're not always just parents
but the family members have to change
how they respond to their loved ones and
validation if somebody said that before
is the core program validation I'm aware
time so I'm going to rush through the
next one observing limits some people
arrive and they they've not ever least
recently been able to have limits or
know what limits are the sort of in the
sea floating along so we teach them to
identify limits in their own life that
they can turn themselves into a rock
that the word no can be said with
gentleness and love it said thoughtfully
and that finding a limits if you don't
know what to do about let's say a
situation you don't to do it saying this
exceeds my limits least plants a flag
for who you are what your values are and
it's going to and your loved ones going
to know you have those values so it's a
little a little turn that people have to
make this
regain the fact like an apple and it's
different from setting boundaries it's
not putting a fence around the person
you're identifying what you to do right
you can't make them do anything but you
can decide what you want to do our
children now know when they call up and
ask for something so I know you have to
talk to dad and we always say I want
time to think about it it's also a key
thing that we tell our families take
time to think you don't have to answer
right away the next one is mindfulness
and I think we all know about
mindfulness our family members don't
really know about it but teaching them
is a true gift is paying attention it's
really paying attention and cutting out
all of the Li ambient noise and all the
sounds and really listening to them of
what they're saying and sometimes you
don't even have to say anything all you
have to do is listen we are very big on
meditation and of course you can do the
meditation that Deepak Chopra just did
he did the 21-day meditation but we have
one that we send our families is called
get some head space calm and it's a
lovely British feller who talks and he
teaches you how to acknowledge the fact
that you're having a thought and you're
it's interrupting and you just pass it
off and go back to your breathing and
that's what I liked about his program is
get some head space com that's
mindfulness so a radical radical
acceptance of the confusion with radical
acceptances people can view it as I'm
approving something or resigned and we
say no radical acceptance and and this
is tricky we keep coming back to a
dealing with it you need to go over and
over again radical acceptance simply
means you accept that this is reality
this is the universe the asteroid has
hit the planet and the dinosaurs are
gone we've hit an iceberg and now how do
we go forward from here only with
radical acceptance I think we've come to
believe only when you do that can you
actually start looking at change when
you look at reality and people have said
things like I don't know how to accept
that how do i how do I accept that and
the simple answer maybe it's too glib is
well if that's the reality
then that's the reality and then we
teach you know about going out and
looking at the sky and saying okay
universe you know the universe makes its
own rules and whatever happens happens
right struggles these are struggles that
our family members often have when they
come in they struggle with anger they're
still angry they're angry at their their
loved ones the loved ones are angry at
them and it's it's matthew slit does our
little transactional dance that we did
that somebody did up there before the
transaction between the two of them how
you affect the others anger according to
alan frazzetti is toxic to the border
lot to the borderline it's too spicy and
anger has no place in a family
environment you're welcome Alan they
struggle with the limits idea
essentially because let's say things are
going well they can get lulled in the
sense there are things okay and then
when things aren't okay they have to
reimburse the earth except the fact that
you know there's going to be times that
things are working well and times that
things aren't working well so these are
the things they wrestle and we spent a
lot of time we try not to rush past we
welcome when people challenge us on
these things because it's important that
we really pick it apart and see how it's
working right change it is very hard for
families to change and they feel why do
I have to change I'm not the one with
the problem they're the one with the
problem I don't have a problem and we
say well actually it's that
transactional dance again where you have
they have a problem and you're making it
worse or you're not paying attention so
they do have to change and unbelievably
the family members do change after 12
weeks of a lot of support a lot of
information and a lot of skills and they
do and there was what I would tell it
quick family is that the one that I was
going to do no that's practice okay
that's really funny I have a funny story
with acceptance they they'll wrestle
with acceptance of what we'll do is
we'll have activities will say can you
identify something you've radically
accepted and then at the same time can
you identify something they're still
struggling to radically
except so they keep reading gauging with
that and we do the same thing we do the
activity at the same time because this
thing's we write that's true making
sense of it all and after 12 weeks we
tell them to practice on the little
things like going into the grocery store
and oh no my favorite one is going to
macy's and i'm returning something and
the girls on the telephone and I'm
standing there and I have to get this
thing returned and she's on the
telephone and now in previous days I
start to get the knots in my stomach I
say oh my god this is driving me nuts
but I learned now to benignly assume
that she's talking to an old friend
somebody she has seen in awhile and it
calms me down and as we know you get
more bees with honey and I go I hope
everything's okay and it's practice its
practice and we tell them to do the
practice all the time and we also help
them to try to stop being disappointed
all the time our family members get
disappointed that things aren't working
or didn't happen or my child did the
same thing over and over again and I
just can't make them stop well they can
stop being disappointed because now you
can radically accept that this is how
your loved one is and then you can stop
being disappointed and stop being
surprised who's at homer simpson bangs
his head just out out out all the time
he just keeps hitting his head and we
teach them skills so that you're not
surprised and you're not disappointed in
your loved one and your remaining much
calmer you're always calm we always say
we're fifty percent of the relationship
with our children with our loved ones
and we're the ones who are in control
protection control potentially we would
like to do a little on the fly edit way
I think we have about tops five minutes
and whatever could you just do this one
slide here we'll run through it in the
order we having the skills out yeah um
well yeah I just have backed us on the
small things but the quick story is we
had a family member who he was not into
anything he was done he was done and
okay oh sorry he was done well I had to
show my antonsen and he said my daughter
wants to its februari she wants to take
the car his brand-new cherokee laredo
and drive up to Vermont and he's going
oh my god and he's been in the class
there were eight times and his wife is
not home and he doesn't know what to do
and he's done so he says I'm gonna have
to talk it over with your mom um I'm
gonna need some time to think so I said
so what happened he said nothing she
said okay and he tried it and it worked
he didn't scream and yell at or what I'm
not giving you that car he and he was
done he's not done any more it was great
okay secondly the importance of practice
and small things before we do our group
I read some from dick not on I hope you
know him and tick not hon says when you
make a cup of tea make a cup of tea so
being being very you know if you're
going to be mindful to be mindful in a
situation that could be dire or
situations crisis you probably should be
practicing when you're making a cup of
tea and someone says oh look it's a full
moon stop turn seriously take in the
moon be mindful in that moment and then
when I love with Stacy did she said Oh
water it's cold she was mindful that the
looks like true at the moment that your
presentation disappeared you said right
Cold War and one can appreciate it
alright little small jigs right so
role-playing we do a lot of role-playing
a lot of the role of playing is organic
a family member will say um I need to do
this how do I get her to do this and so
will stop and we'll role play with the
family member so it just do a quick one
here um dad I need the car keys right
now really well the car wait in the car
what's for I'm just have to go to the
pharmacy if I don't pick up those pills
they're just gonna be gone what are you
you need some pill bug medicine I need
my meds I need my vitamins I I need some
shampoo I have a lot of men what
medications your honor just not you know
my meds well you're out of all them no
I'm out of some of them okay um but I
need the car no I that's important you
really should have your medication um
your mom and I have spoken and the car
is really not available
I do new ring I I think that you know
getting your medication I'd be glad to
take you down when I finished filling
the dishwasher okay all right look I'll
help you finish the dishwasher can we
just go go to do this do that and we
would do something like that he didn't
make it worse so a little on the brow
there's only a couple skills is little
fact-checking yeah a little validation
I'm getting that she's agitated by it
and then a little problem son can't
always problem-solve to be sure let's
see sharing things and sharing successes
we do that in small groups we get I give
them a they get a card that says what
something that's going to like the
radical acceptance or the validation and
they share in small groups sometimes we
have groups too sometimes they have
groups of three and then they come back
and talk I know we're getting we're
getting the boot here yes I don't for
the for the last item when things don't
work this doesn't work all the time does
this not work all the time and what we
say is that I'm not being in sports
metaphors but you know you're trying to
have a win-win and you want have a
winning season so you can blow a game
you can lose your temper things can not
go well and you don't dough should of I
should have done this I could have done
this we don't have time machines what
you can do is you can analyze what
happened and say okay next time maybe
have a script playing out ahead similar
situation about the car comes plan for
the next time and try to build the sense
that you're as I said having a winning
season even though I don't do sports
metaphors we're not gonna do this Lex I
think we are in fact out of time right I
wrong okay but thank you for the await
us thanks you after you have a lot of
people to thank you I have Perry Hoffman
to thank I have Alan frazzetti to thank
i have my poli evangelia to thank i have
Louise sticks is not here we have way up
there are you still there Trish no
Trisha somewhere and all of our family
members who are here today thank you
very much and kamila wet who's always
there for us okay so thank you
you